[Music]
hey bubble you
done chatting up our arch nemesis
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me don't touch your ear like that
you look like an idiot
you gotta move on
[Music]
make my way
[Music]
oh your upstairs seems pissed is that
something i should be worried about just
stay focused
keep an eye on him for me
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's get started then with lot
number one a magnificent oil on copper
our lady of good counsel by bartolome
perez
hello
[Music]
six hundred thousand going once going
twice
sold to the lady of the back thank you
very much
cross is up next kid
um
sully don't worry i got it
now most of you will know this was made
in barcelona circa 16th century it is
truly a gorgeous piece and
representative of spanish renaissance
gold work so we're going to start off
tonight's bidding at 200 000. do i have
200 000 in the room
thank you very much i have an opening
bit of 200 000 from mr moncada
okay here we go who am i here for how we
doing
you're doing great
500 000 it is do i have six i have six
thank you very much madam i don't have
all nineteen seven seven hundred
thousand from mr moncada do we have
eight
no takers
so fair warning on seven hundred
thousand that is seven hundred going let
me do this seven hundred going twice
and
there we are at the back of the room
thank you very much sir we have eight
hundred thousand eight hundred thousand
is bid ladies and gentlemen do i have
nine i'm spending money i don't have
okay here goes nothing
[Music]
oh god i shouldn't have come out to play
with that big boy's win because you're
about to get a proper scottish welcome
i'm sorry
mr moncado it's back to you now 1.9
mr moncado makes it an even 2 million
dollars later again oh train's already
left the station right why not 2.1 thank
you very much indeed mr mankata over to
you any advances on that
2.2 we have 2.2 ladies and gentlemen oh
my god here she comes ah
come here
i literally have no idea what you're
saying
2.2 is what we have do i have 2.3 he
goes with it mr moncada takes it to 3
million dollars
stupid door
oh okay
um
sully i think you're just gonna have to
buy that cross
three million dollars it is you've got
to do something now kill the power fake
a heart attack i don't give a [ __ ]
twice
and
this is gonna suck
oh that was something
what's it brand new well at least you're
fat ass you can't come out here and get
me small situation
just a second
can
you're doing great hang in there
oh [ __ ]
hey trent addison wanted me to take that
to the vault pronto
thanks
sully where you going
you can't leave me there's only one role
in this game kid don't get caught
[Music]
you